Preheat the oven to give an output flux density in the infrared regime of 7 yocto nanomaggies.
Then make sure to grease and line two 6.5. attoparsec sandwich tins.
Break four ergs into a large mixing bowl,
(that's eggs, not ergs)
Break four e̶r̶g̶s into a large mixing bowl,
then mix in 126 yottaelectron volts per speed of light squared of both sugar and flour
with 2 barn-megaparsecs of baking powder, and 0.06 Hubble-barns of butter.
Divide the mixture evenly between the two tins and bake the cakes on the middle shelf of the oven for 3 femto-Hubbell times.
Sandwich together with jam, once cooled, and sprinkle it with some castor sugar for decoration.
And there you have it, a physics-inspired Victoria sponge cake.